at the agriculture and Fisheries Council
on the 14th of July the Italian
presidency will set out its work program
priorities for the next six months there
will be a debate on organic farming
following the presentation of a proposal
in March for a review of the legislation
concerning organic production and
farming in Europe the debate will focus
on which elements of flexibility should
be introduced how more effective and
targeted controls should be put in place
and the type of delegated act to
consider at this council that could be
agreement on the way forwards for the
dairy sector if diverging positions
amongst member states are resolved some
Member States urge for additional
measures before the end of the quota
system next year in order to ensure a
proper soft landing or a more
economically gentle transition whilst
other member states are asking for
measures for the future of the sector to
avoid a crisis after the end of the
quota system regarding fisheries there
will be an exchange of views between
ministers based on the Commission's
proposals concerning total allowable
catches for 2015 this includes the state
of the stocks and a limited overview of
the economic performance of the EU fleet
it also takes into account as agreed in
the reformed Common Fisheries Policy the
upcoming landing obligation where
oarfish court must be brought ashore and
counted as part of the total catch this
will pave the way for decisions to be
made on specific fish stocks later in
the year
I